[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع ليلى الاختيار استهلها بابرز
العدو
بجلسه استجواب لمديره التنفيذي الكونغرس
بالتحريضي
لمواجهه الصين وينقل طائرات حديثه من
الشرق الاوسط الى جنوب شرق اسيا
بنشر توقعات خاطئه حول اعتقاله لدفع
الجمهوريين بالتدخل بالتحقيق
[موسيقى]
الخميس الاسود يشعل فرنسا قطع من الطرقات
واشتباكات بين الامن ومتظاهرين حول قانون
التقاعد
[موسيقى]
نبدا مشاهدينا من المواجهه الامريكيه ضد
تطبيق تيك توك الصيني حيث اتهم الكونجرس
اثناء جلسه الاستماع لرئيس التنفيذي لتيك
توك اتهم التطبيق الصيني بنشر فيديو يحمل
تهديدا مباشره لرئيسه الجلسه واتهم الشركه
بتزويد الحكومه الصينيه ببيانات
المستخدمين هذا وضع الكونغرس لتقييد
الوصول الى تيك توك في الولايات المتحده
وقال ان التطبيق يقوم بانتهاكات منذ فتره
طويله ويجب وقف هذا الضرر
تيك توك
محاولات اخيره اجراها رئيس التنفيذي لشركه
تيك توك شوتشي بهدف انقاذ التطبيق من
الحظر في الولايات المتحده شو خلال جلسه
للادلاء بشهاداته امام الكونغرس شدد ان
الشركه تاخذ المخاوف الامريكيه على محمل
الجد وجدد الرئيس التنفيذي لتيك توك
بوعوده بان الشركه لن تسمح بالتلاعب
ببيانات المستخدمين من اي جهه وانهم طبعا
ملتزمون بحمايه المستخدمين الامريكيين هذا
وسع رئيس تيك توك لاقناع المشرعين بان
التطبيق الذي يضم 150 مليون مستخدم في
الولايات المتحده وحدها لا يشكل خطرا على
الامريكيين او يشارك البيانات مع الحكومه
الصينيه فلنستمع لمقاله
لدينا اكثر من مليار مستخدم بينهم 150
مليون في امريكا وضعنا تدابير لمنع ارسال
رسائل نصيه للمستخدمين دون 16 عاما ولا
نعارض اي مساله تتعلق بالخصوصيه تم بناء
جدران حمايه للبيانات الامريكيه وباشراف
موظفين امريكيين وهم فقط من يمكنهم الوصول
للبيانات الامريكيه التي ستكون تحت رقابه
الوكالات الامنيه الامريكيه اننا ناخذ
المخاوف الاميركيه على محمل الجد ولن نسمح
بالتلاعب ببيانات المستخدمين من اي جهه
مسؤوليتنا تتمثل في حمايه المستخدمين
الامريكيين وملتزمون بذلك نحن الشركه
الوحيده التي تقدم بيانات شفافه لسنا شركه
حكوميه وستون في المئه من الاستثمارات
اجنبيه
لكن يبدو كل هذه الوعود والمبررات لم تقنع
الكونجرس الامريكي الذي حذر من ان تيك توك
يشكل خطرا على بيانات الامريكيين ويجب ان
يتحلى بالشفافيه الكونغرس قال ايضا ان
الحزب الشيوعي الصيني قد يخترق هواتف
الامريكيين عبر هذا التطبيق وطلب الشركه
لضبط المحتوى وعدم تحوله لاداه للتجسس
[موسيقى]
ومع هذه الشهاده على وجه الخصوص من الواضح
ان يواجه معركه عبثيه وسط ترجيحات بان
المرشحين او المشرعين الرئيسيين في اللجنه
اتخذوا القرار بالفعل وفي هذا الاطار تشمل
خطه تيك توك البالغه مليار و500 مليون
دولار وضع البيانات الامريكيه في خوادم
محليه مملوكه لشركه اورك الكرب والسماح
بمراجعه خوارزميه هذه الشركه
وتوصيات تيك توك
حظر وشيك يتعرض له تطبيق تيك توك في
الولايات المتحده بعد التهديد الاخير
بالبيع او الحظر الكامل ومعارضه الحكومه
الصينيه الخطط الامريكيه لاجبار الملاك
على بيعه عواقب القرار الامريكي المرتقب
لا تواجه الشركه الصينيه فحسب بل طالت
المعلنين
فعائدات التطبيق الصيني من الاعلانات في
الولايات المتحده في ازدياد غير مسبوق قد
تصل هذه العائدات الى سته مليارات وثمائه
مليون دولار هذا العام بحسب شركه انسايدر
انتلجنس للابحاث حيث يحظى التطبيق بشعبيه
واسعه ويملك حاليا 150 مليون مستخدم شهريا
في الولايات المتحده
الامر الذي سيجعل هؤلاء المعلنين يراقبون
مصير ازمه تيك توك عن كثب قبل ان يقرروا
الاعلان في التطبيق
تتعرض الشركه لضغوط متزايده من مسؤولين
ونواب امريكيين بسبب مخاوف تتعلق بالامن
القومي
وتحديدا في بيانات المستخدمين التي يرون
انها قد تقع في يد الحكومه الصينيه رغم
تاكيد الرئيس التنفيذي لتيك توك ان الشركه
لم تشارك ابدا هذه البيانات وهي نفس التهم
التي تواجهها المنصه في عدد من دول اوروبا
التي قامت بحظر التطبيق جزئيا
وفي ملف تيك توك ايضا اقر البرلمان
البريطاني اليوم ما اقرته الحكومه في حظر
تطبيق تيك توك ما يحرم المشرعين من الوصول
الى تطبيق الفيديو الصيني عبر شركه
الانترنت الخاصه به وقال مجلس العموم ان
التطبيق سيحضر كل الاجهزه المرتبطه
بالبرلمان والشبكه البرلمانيه الاوسع
نطاقا للامن السيبراني كونه يمثل اولويه
قصوى بالنسبه الى البرلمان البريطاني
وسيبقى بامكان المشرعين استخدام تيك توك
على هواتفهم الخاصه لكن ليس عند الاتصال
بشبكه الانترنت الخاصه بالبرلمان
تنضم الينا من واشنطن للتسليمان مراسله
العربيه ريتا يعني كل هذا التصعيد بوجه
التطبيق الصيني يعني الصيني اليوم ايضا
كان لها رد على هذا الموضوع الى ماذا خلص
بنهايه هذا النهار بعد يعني اتهام
الكونجرس للرئيس التنفيذي للشركه
فاشله الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه تيك توك
شوزيد شو من اقناع لجنه اعضاء لجنه الطاقه
والتجاره في
الكونغرس من
امكانيه
من امكانيه شركه تيك توك من حمايه
البيانات المستخدمين الامريكيين انتقد
المشرعون بشده تيك توك وانتقدوا الاجراءات
التي تتخذها الشركه وخاصه
خطه مشروع تكساس الذي وضعته شركه تيك توك
لحمايه البيانات بيانات المستخدمين
الامريكيين وكما ذكرت ليال هذا هذه الخطه
بلغت حوالي 1.5 مليار دولار ولكنها فاشله
باقناع اللجنه
بامكانيات حمايه المستخدمين
الامريكيين من اي تدخل للحكومه الصينيه او
حتى من المحتوى المض مضلل والضار
الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه تيك توك ايضا فشله
في الاجابه بشكل مباشر وصريح عن امكانيه
عدم تمكن اي موظف من الشركه الام باي دانس
الموجوده في الصين من الدخول الى
حسابات المستخدمين الامريكيين مثل ما حصل
في ديسمبر الماضي حيث تمكن مجموعه من
الموظفين من الدخول الى حسابات عدد من
الصحفيين الامريكيين على التيك توك على
الرغم من كل
الاجراءات التي تم اتخاذها حينها في تيك
توك مطارد هؤلاء الموظفين واجراء
التحقيقات الداخليه ولكن ذلك لم يقنع
اعضاء اللجنه
يعني احد الحلول المطروحه اليوم هي وضع
خوادم هناك فيها كل البيانات حول
المستخدمين اتحدث عن خوادم موجوده
بالولايات المتحده ولكن الحكومه الصينيه
تقول بان كل ما تفعله الاداره الامريكيه
هو لحث الشركه وللضغط على الشركه لبيعها
الى مستثمرين امريكيين ماذا يعني بخلاصه
هذا الموضوع ايضا
الحكومه الصينيه لم تساعد الرئيس التنفيذي
لتيك توك ايضا في هذه الجلسه عبر الاعلان
بانه اي عمليه بيع اجباريه لن تتم
الموافقه عليها ولن تسمح بها الحكومه
الصينيه الامر الذي
وضع تعقيدات على خطه الرئيس التنفيذي لتيك
توك ولم يتمكن من اقناع اعضاء اللجنه خاصه
بعد هذا التصريح اليوم مزيد من التحقيقات
مطلوبه حول دور الحكومه الصينيه في
في تيك توك وفي الحسابات وايضا المزيد من
التوضيحات والشفافيه فيما خاص مشروع تكساس
الذي تقوم تيك توك بانه
خطه شامله كامله لحمايه حسابات المستخدمين
الامريكيين شكرا لك سليمان مراسله العربيه
حدثنا من واشنطن
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا قبل ان اكمل سننتقل الى باريس
وهذه الصور المباشره لمواجهات دائره بهذه
الاثناء بين المتظاهرين وبين الشرطه
الفرنسيه سنستمع قليلا واعود للتعليق على
هذه الصور
[تصفيق]
اذا عمليات كار وكار كل يعني طيله الساعات
الماضيه بين المتظاهرين الفرنسيين وبين
قوات الامن الفرنسيه بعد هذه التظاهره
التي دعت اليها النقابات الفرنسيه وطبعا
كان هناك دعوه شعبيه كبيره للنزول الى
الشارع بما سمي الخميس الاسود
للتظاهر والاعتراض طبعا على قانون التقاعد
الذي رفعت بموجبه الحكومه الفرنسيه سن
التقاعد من 62 عاما الى 64 عاما كما اصبح
معلوم وهو محل رفض شعبي ونقابه وسياسي
طبعا خلال التاسعه سنكون مع المراسلين
وزملائنا الموجودين في باريس للحديث عن
هذه التظاهره ونقل الصوره من هناك
كمان مشاهد مشاهدينا على الشاشه الان
الحكومه الفرنسيه تقدر عدد المحتاجين في
الخميس الاسود باكثر من مليون شخص طبعا
يعني بحسب الزملاء هناك كان من المتوقع ان
تكون هناك مظاهره مليونيه بجميع المناطق
الفرنسيه احتجاجا على هذا القانون على ما
يبدو ان الشارع الفرنسي لن يهدا ستبقى هذه
التظاهرات مفتوحه حتى يعني
خرق الاحداث خرق او على الاقل استجابه
الحكومه لاي مطالب طبعا الموقف الرسمي
الفرنسي كما شاهدنا بالامس بمقابله الرئيس
الفرنسي ما زالت عند حاله هو يعتبر بان
هذا التشريع ضروره وبان لا عوده عليها
طبعا تطورات الساعات المقبله ممكن ان تغير
شيء ما خصوصا ان هناك اصرار نقابي وشعبي
على احداث حاله من الشلل كما اصبح معلوم
بالقطاعات الاساسيه في الداخل الفرنسي وهو
ما سيضرر اكثر طبعا الاقتصاد الفرنسي الذي
هو اصلا متضرر بفعل كل الازمه الاخيره
الاقتصاديه
بالدول الاوروبيه والحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه
[موسيقى]
اعد واذكر بان هذا التشريع مرر بدون
العوده الى مجلس النواب بسبب عدم وجود
اغلبيه لايمن القوى هناك وبسبب خوف
الحكومه من تطهيره داخل اروقه مجلس النواب
طبعا هذا ما اثار ايضا سخط شعبي كبير بانه
تم تمريره يعني فتوى دستوريه بدون اراده
الشعب وبدون موافقه الشعب الفرنسي عليه
اليسار الفرنسي النقابات طبعا الممثله
باليسار واقصى اليمين واليمين كل الاحزاب
تقريبا ضد هذا التشريع
وطبعا طالبوا الحكومه بالاستقاله طلبوا
عدد كبير من المسؤولين بالرجوعا ولكن على
ما يبدو حتى الساعه بان لا استجابه لا
حكوميه ولا رئاسيه
للمطالب الشعبيه
[تصفيق]
اذا هذه التظاهره التي
سميت بالخميس الاسود هي تاتي ضمن سلسله
التظاهرات بدات منذ اسابيع في جميع
المناطق الفرنسيه وهي تصعيديه بكل جمعه
يعني الناس نشاهد الاعداد تكبر اكثر فاكثر
مع تعنت الحكومه هناك تعنت شعبي بان لا
خروج من الشارع قبل استجابه الحكومه وجهات
الرسميه الفرنسيه للمطالب الشعبيه التي
تطالب الرجوع عن القانون الذي اصبح معلوم
هو قانون التقاعد الذي عدل سن التقاعد من
62 عاما الى 64 عاما
اذا المشاهدينا ما زلنا مع هذه الصور
المباشره ساعود بعد قليل الى الزملاء في
باريس خلال سياق التاسعه
قال مسؤول مسؤولون امريكيون لصحيفات جون
الامريكيه ان الولايات المتحده سترسل
طائرات هجوميه متقادمه من طراز ايتان
لتحويل محل طائرات مقاتله اكثر تطورا في
الشرق الاوسط وذلك كجزء من جهود
البانتاجون لنقل المزيد من المقاتلات
الحديثه الى المحيط الهادئ واوروبا لردع
الصين وروسيا واضاف المسؤولون الامريكيون
للصحيفه ان عمليه نقل طائرات ايتن المقرر
اجراؤها في اي بريل هي جزء من خطه اوسع
تدعو ايضا الى الاحتفاظ بقوات بحريه وبريه
محدوده في منطقه الشرق الاوسط والتركيز
على مواجهه نفوذ الصين وروسيا وانه بموجب
هذه الخطه سيتمركز سرب من طائرات ايتان في
المنطقه الى جانب سردين من طائرات اف 15
وافته 16
وثمان بطاريات باتريوت للدفاع الجوي
يبدو ان كلمات الرئيس الصيني حين كان يقف
امام نظيره الروسي اربكت صوره القطب
الواحد التي تستقتل الولايات المتحده
للحفاظ عليها حين قال ان يوافقه بوتا
سريعا
اليوم تنشر صحيفه وستري جونل تقريرا يشير
الى دخول الجيش الامريكي حقبه جديده من
منافسه القوى العظمى روسيا والصين ضمن
استراتيجيه 2014 الشاملات تجاه اسيا تخطط
الولايات المتحده لنشر طائرات هجوميه
متقادمه من طراز اي عشره في الشرق الاوسط
كبديل لمقاتلات اكثر تطورا تنقلها الى
المحيط الهادئ واوروبا ابريل القادم
المسؤولون الامريكيون ذكروا للصحيفه ان
تقارير تخلص الى انه لا توجد طائرات
مقاتله كافيه لمواجهه التحدي الصيني
المتزايد والعدوان الروسي كما سموه بموجب
الخطه الجديده سيتمركز سرب من طائرات اي
10 في المنطقه الى جانب سربين من طائرات
اف 15 اي واف سته عشر بمعدل حوالي 12
طائره للسرب
في السابق لقد خطوه القوات الجويه بالتخلص
التدريجي من طائرات اي 10 وصيانتها لتوفير
الاموال لبرامج اخرى مقاومه كبيره من
الكونجرس فبالنسبه للطائره التي يبلغ
عمرها 14 عقود قد يكون اداؤها محرجا امام
مواجهه مع طائرات صينيه من الجيل الحديث
اننا نتقاعد من طائرات اي 10 اسرع مما كنا
نعتقد لن تكون الموازنه بين الشرق الاوسط
والاقصى عمليه سهله لكنها ضروريه وعاجله
فهي اولا وكما تراها واشنطن مساله تهديد
لقواتها ومصالحها غير ان متقاعدين من
الجويه الامريكيه ذكروا للصحيفه ان نشر
طائرات ضعيفه في المنطقه سيقوض من قدره
الجيش الامريكي وصموده امام خطر مستقبلي
لم يحسب له حساب في قرار اليوم كالربح
النووي العربيه
دفع وزير الدفاع الامريكي خلال كلمه
القاها امام الكونجرس عن موازنه الدفاع
الجديده بحجه التصدي لقدرات الصين
العسكريه المتزايده وبرى
842 مليار دولار الذي يتضمنته الميزانيه
بالحاجه الى بناء قدرات عسكريه في المحيط
الهادئ وبدوره حذر قائد الاركان الامريكيه
مارك ميلي من مواجهه عسكريه محتمله مع
بيكين وهو ما يستدعي اعاده تاهيل القوات
الامريكيه المنهكه بعد حربي العراق
وافغانستان وخلال الجلسه نفسها وافق
الكونجرس على قانون ميزانيه الدفاع
الجديده
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من واشنطن الدكتور
وليد فارس الباحث في السياسه الخارجيه
الامريكيه دكتور وليد سابدا بموضوع
الانسحاب من الشرق الاوسط نحن اليوم يعني
امام استكمال صاحب الطائرات طبعا السحب
العسكري الثقيل من الشرق الاوسط هي
السياسه الاوباميه التي بداها اوباما مع
تركيز الثقل العسكري الامريكي بالمحيطين
الهندي والهادئ باعتبار ان هناك يعني
الخطر الحقيقي على وجود واشنطن هذا
الانسحاب اليوم ماذا يعني وماذا ينظر
للمرحله المقبله
شكرا كما تفضلت السيده الانسحاب الاول
السياسه الاولى كانت سياسه اداره الرئيس
اوباما ولكن السبب الحقيقي لها كان حسب ما
علمنا ان بما انه سيوقع اتفاق مع ايران
وايران هي الخطر الاساسي التي يحتاج كل
هذه الانتشارات العسكريه كان وقت الخطه
وقتها ان تنسحب او اعاده تموقع القوات
الامريكيه في المحيط الهادي اين وكيف هذه
كانت امور سوف تناقش عندما جاءت اداره
ترامب اصبح هنالك اصطدام مع الايرانيين
فلم يتم اعاده التموقع الان هالخطه هي
الخطه القديمه التي تجددها اداره بايدن
وتقوم بتنفيذها خاصه الاسراع الان خاصه
انه الاشتباك او المواجهه بين ايران على
الاقل واحد اطراف المنطقه الفاعلين
المملكه وحلفائها هذا الامر لم يعد واردا
حاليا
[موسيقى]
تدخل بهذا الموضوع ولكن من هنا اتى هذا
يعني تصفير المشاكل بمنطقه الشرق الاوسط
بسبب علم يعني انشغال الاداره بالملف
الاخر بموضوع المواجهه العسكريه مع الصين
اليوم هناك تحذير امريكي وحديثي يعني جدي
اكثر بكثير من المرحله المقبله عن اقتراب
المواجهه العسكريه مع الصين هل المصلحه
الامريكيه اليوم هي بحرب عسكريه مع الصين
لا انا لا اعتقد انه احد عنده مصلحه يدخل
بحرب خاصه بين قوتان عظيمتان نوويتان وكل
الاطراف تعرفها موسكو والصين والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والغرب ولكن التصعيد
السياسي والتعبئه والانتشار هو جزء من
السياسه الدبلوماسيه يعني نحن نذكر عندما
الرئيس ترامب وقتها ارسل بقوتان عسكريتان
الى الشبه القاره الكوريه عندما كان يهدد
الرئيس كيم انه سوف يطلق الصواريخ هاي
تسمى الدبلوماسيه العسكريه اذا اعاده
الانتشار في مواقع مواجهه للصين هي تغطن
على الصين بنهايه المطاف والصين تقوم بنفس
الشيء عندما تقوم بمناورات بمناطق اخرى من
العالم
اليوم يعني بالمرحله الماضيه بالسنوات
الماضيه اصبحنا نقول بان الحرب الاقتصاديه
هي الاساس بالحروب بهذا القرض اليوم يعني
موسكو بدات تكسر هذه القاعده شيئا ما بان
باستطاعه هذه الانظمه الاستمرار حتى مع
حرب اقتصاديه وعسكريه بسبب التكتلات
الجديده التي نشات هل هذه الزاويه دفعت
واشنطن الى التركيز اكثر على موضوع التسلح
والعوده الى الخيار العسكري مره اخرى
النقطه الاولى انه هذه النظريه قد ثبتت
اكثر من انه قد تم نقدها في مجره لانه كان
هنالك عقوبات كبيره وواسعه جدا على موسكو
وكانت السؤال الكبير هل بامكان موسكو ان
تصمد امامها الذي حدث انه موسكو استعانت
بالصين والصين اعطت موسكو قليلا وليس
الكثير لجعل موسكو قادره على الصمود هو
الذي حدث تغيير المعادلات تغيير التحالفات
الاقتصاديه والصين منذ 20 عام 25 عام
تستفيد لتقوي عضلاتها الاقتصاديه معظم
الديون الامريكيه التريليونات موجوده في
الصين والصين لها عقود مع دول يعني في
ثلاث قارات هذا لم يكن موجودا في الماضي
هذا ما اثر اذا الاقتصاد والحروب
الاقتصاديه لا تزال هي هي ولكن التموقع او
التصور الامريكي انهم اننا عندنا القدره
ان نربح اي حرب اقتصاديه هذا بدا يتغير
بتقديره اما الموضوع العسكري في الصناعات
العسكريه دائما تحب ان تصرف على
نفسها
وتستفيد من الازمات شكرا لك يا دكتور وليد
فارس الباحث في السياسه الخارجيه حدثنا من
اشرطه
في الولايات المتحده ايضا قال مدعي عامه
ان الرئيس الامريكي سابق دونالد ترامب
تسبب بتوقعات خاطئه بشان اعتقاله مضيفا ان
دوافع سياسيه وراء تصريحات ترامب واشار
الى ان تدخلات المشرعين في قضيه ترامب
انتهاك لقانون وسيادات نيويورك كما ان
تصريحات الرئيس السابق دفعت لجمهوريين
للتدخل في التحقيقات كما رفض مدعى من هاتم
طلب الكونغرس لاستجوابه والكشف عن حيثيات
قضيه ترامب
[موسيقى]
التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
نتنياهو يستدعي وزير دفاع اسرائيل بسبب
ضغطه لوقف التعديلات القضائيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد نستكمل التاسعه من الحرب
في اوكرانيا حيث قالت الاستخبارات
البريطانيه ان روسيا تمكنت بعد قتالا عنيف
منذ بدايه الشهر الجاري من السيطره على
مناطق قريبه والمداخل المؤديه لمدينه
كريميا على خط المواجهه في لوغاسك واشارت
في بيان لها ان روسيا حققت تقدما بعده
كيلومترات باتجاه مركز
وتخطط للتوسع غربا وصولا الى نهر اسكل
لتعزيز خطوط الدفاع ولفتت ايضا الى
احتمالات بنيه روسيه لاستعاده او بنيه
روسيه لاستعاده مدينه كوبيانس في خرز
لاهميتها الاستراتيجيه هذا واكدت
الاستخبارات البريطانيه ان الوضع لعمل
جبهات الشماليه الشرقيه يشير الى ان روسيا
تتخذ وضعا دفاعيا للحفاظ على المكاسب مع
اي هجوم اوكرانيا كبير
وفي قضيه الذخائر او ذخائر اليورانيوم
البريطانيه الى كييف اعلن المتحدث باسم
وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه ماريا زخرفه بانه
سيكون من المستحيل السيطره على عواقب
الاشعاع المنبعث من استخدام قذائف
اليورانيوم المنظف في اوكرانيا واشارت
زخرفه في افاده صحفيه انه سيكون من
المستحيل على دول المجاوره السيطره على
عواقب استخدام الاسلحه والقذائف التي
تحتوي على اليورانيوم المنظم
باصدار محكمه الجنايات الدوريه قرارا
باعتقال بوتين عاد الجدل حول صلاحيات
المحكمه وقدرتها على تنفيذ القرار لكن
خطوه مماثله تجاه رئيس دوله نوويه كبرى
تطرح المزيد من التساؤلات حول المفعول
الحقيقي لهذا القرار فلنتابع
نووي روسيا ضامن امنها وحليفها الوحيد
عقيده ولدت من رحم الحرب البارده وامتدت
لروسيا الحديثه الا ان موسكو اليوم اشهرت
سلاحها النوويه من اجل ضمان حريه رئيسها
اعتقال بوتين في المانيا مثلا يعني اعلان
الحرب على روسيا وفي هذه الحاله سنستخدم
كل امكانياتنا بما في ذلك الصواريخ التي
تستهدف البوندستاج ومكتب المستشار رد
روسيا ضد محكمه الجنايات الدوليه لم يتاخر
وتراوح بين مقاضاه المسؤولين عن القرار
وصولا الى التهديد بضرب مقرها في لاهاي
بصاروخ فرط صوتي اعتقال بوتين جاء من دون
مقدمات خاصه وان الامر لم يتعلق بجرائم
حرب ارتكبها جيشه ولا حتى شركه فاجنر بل
الامر يخص ترحيل اطفال اوكرانيين من مئه
ميتم منتشر في مناطق سيطرت عليها روسيا
وجه ه الاطفال كانت عائلات روسيه للاصغر
سنا اما البقيه فهم معنيون ايضا بنزع
النازيه سته الاف طفل اوكراني نقلوا الى
مراكز اعاده تاهيل اين تدرس اللغه الروسيه
وروايه الكريم للتاريخ تقول مصادر امريكيه
مذكره اعتقال بحق رئيس دوله نوويه كبرى
سابقه في التاريخ لكن فصل المحكمه في قضيه
تتعلق ببلد لا يعترف بالمحكمه بخصوص جرائم
وقعت في بلد اخر هو ايضا لا يعترف بدوره
باختصاص المحكمه حدث غير مسبوق محكمه
لاهاي اعتبرت اعلان كييف شفويا قبول
اختصاص المحكمه قبل اسابيع مبررا يوازي في
مفعوله انضمامها لاتفاقيه روما المؤسسه
تبرير وصفه الكريم بالمهزله وهو ما ينطبق
على امريكا التي باركته ايضا وهي لا تعترف
بدورها بالمحكمه اما التحقيقات فهي مسرحيه
اعتمدت على نتائج توصلت اليها محكمه
اوكرانيه
123 دوله التزمت باتفاقيات روما لكنها لن
تكون كلها قادره على تنفيذ القرار اما
خوفا او تقديرا للصداقه التي تجمعها
بروسيا الا ان القرار يحمل ثقلا رمزيا لا
يزول بالتقادم
ومواجهته هاجس سيرافق بوتين الى اخر ايامه
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من موسكو عبر زوم
السفير اندريه مستشار رئيسه المجلس
الفيدرالي الروسي استاذ ابدا من موضوع
الاجتماعات الروسيه الامريكيه حول الشرق
الاوسط وسوريا الى ماذا خلصت هذه
الاجتماعات التي يعني انتهت منذ وقت قريب
من المثير للاهتمام انه
رغم حاله
الخلاف والشقاق الواضحه بين الاتحاد
الروسي والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
اكثر فان المتخصصين والخبراء
لم يقوموا
باضاعه فرصه عقد اي اجتماع
وخلال هذه السنه
وتحديدا اليوم ويوم الغد لسوف يكون لدينا
اربع اجتماع اربعه اجتماعات بين الخبراء
رفيعي المستوى من الولايات المتحده
وشرق الاوسط
للنظر في الوضع الانساني الذي تشهده سوريا
ولا بد لي ان اشير بان الاجواء
في هذه الاجتماعات كانت طبيعيه للغايه وما
من توتر عاشته ابدا
وناقشنا كل هذه القضايا ومن كفر كافه
الزوايا حول التوصل لامرين في نفس الوقت
اولهما العمل
على
الاستفاده من
ما تم الوصول اليه من مصالحات في سوريا
والعمل على تعزيز الواقع الانساني والعمل
الانساني في الشرق الاوسط واجتماع اليوم
على وجه التحديد كان ناجحا للغايه
وسوف نستمر في عقد في جلستنا يوم الغد
وسوف نتحلى
بالصراحه في
مناقشاتنا مع
تتحدث عن الملف السوري طبعا الامريكي
متحفظ على الدور الذي تلعبه روسيا اليوم
بموضوع المصالحات لانه يعني من ناحيه ما
تاتي ياتي على حساب حلفاء بشمال سوريا هذه
النقطه تحديدا كيف تطرقتم اليها
اختلافات بشان هذا الملف فهم يعارضون
السلطه القانونيه الموجوده في سوريا بل
ونحن بدورنا ندعمها بالاضافه الى ذلك هناك
قضيه اخرى
تتعلق بالواقع الانساني
ومشكله
وجود القوات في
نقاط متعدده ونسعى بدورنا لتحقيق نوعا من
المعادله
واتمنى ان نحقق نتائج جيده
بموضوع قرار المحكمه الجنائيه ضد الرئيس
بوتين هناك مسؤوله روسيه اعلنت بوقت سابق
عن اجلاء 14 الف طفل من اوكرانيا وهي
سابقه طبعا بالعصر المعاصر ولكن عندما
تقولون بان قرار المحكمه هو قرار خاضع
للاملاءات الامريكيه السياسيه هنا هناك
نقطه اساسيه بان الخلاف بين المحكمه
الجنائيه والولايات المتحده يعود يعني
لعصور وهو ليس بالجديد وبالتالي كيف يمكن
ان يكون قرار سياسي بحث وليس قرار قانوني
اقول لكم ان ان السياسيين المخضرمين
لا يعيرون اهتماما
بمثل هذا القرار لانهم هناك قدره لفبركه
الاف القصص الزائفه
والحكمه تكمن في
المضمون والجوهر
ولن نقوم بابداء ردود افعال بطريقه حماسيه
من اجل الحديث عن اشياء غبيه نسمعها من
الغرب ان رايي وراي معظم السياسيين
المخضرمين في روسيا هو تجاهل
هذا القرار غير القانوني والغبي
الذي
تم اصداره وقد يكون هذا مجرد اختبار
لصبرنا لكن بدورنا نقوم بتجاهله لانه
موقفا غير احترافي
ونناقشه
لقد فقد الناس اهتمامهم بمناقشه هذه القصص
التي نسمع على شاشات التلفزه مئات المرات
في روسيا وخاصه في ظل هذه الاحاديث
السياسيه شكرا
لك
في قلب الجزيره الاندونيسيه بالي هناك
موسكو صغيره اكثر من 22 الف روسيا غادروا
الى الجزيره الاندونيسيه منذ بدء الحرب
بتاشيرات سياحيه فخرقوا شروط التاشيره
ومدتها المحدده وبقيوا في الجزيره هؤلاء
اما توظفوا كمدربين رياضيين ومصورين او
حتى كوميديين او انشاوا اعمالا صغيره غير
ان وجود عشرات الالاف من الروس في
اندونيسيا لم يستغثه سكان بالي الذين
اطلقوا حملات واسعه على وسائل التواصل ضد
التجاوزات الروسيه المزعومه ما دفع
السلطات الى اتخاذ اجراءات صارمه كما اعلن
وزير السياحه الاندونيسي انه سيدرس اقتراح
حاكم بالي حول انهاء اعطاء التاشيرات عند
وصول الروس والاوكرانيين الى الجزيره
[موسيقى]
جيش من الروبوتات يقتحم ويدافع سيناريو
باتا قريبا من الواقع ولا يقتصر على
الافلام فقط فحروب المستقبل قد يقودها
ويقود معاركها رجال اليون وبعد اعلان عن
انضمام روبوتات لصفوف الجيش البريطاني
خلال سبع سنوات تصريح مماثل صدر من الجانب
الامريكي وان كان مداه اطول رئيس هيئه
الاركان الامريكيه المشتركه الجنرال مارك
ميليتوقع ان تشكل روبوتات عماد القوات
المسلحه لدول العالم خلال 15 عاما مقبلا
طبيعه الحرب تتغير في كثير من الاحيان
ولاسباب عده بينها طبعا السلاح الجديد
كالذخائر الدقيقه والدقيقه التوجيه مثلا
لكن التكنولوجيا العاليه وفق الجنرال
الامريكي ستعمل على تغيير طريقه خوض
الحروب كما غيرت قدرات كشف وتشخيص العدو
طريقه الاستهداف الروبوتات مشاهدينا او
الرو الاليه وفقا للتوقعات الغربيه ستدخل
القوات البريه والبحريه والجويه في مختلف
الدول خلال اقل من عقدين حيث تبحث مؤسسات
صناعيه دفاعيه امكانيه استخدام المركبات
القتاليه البريه والسفن بدون طاقم قياده
وتشغيل علما بان معظم الطائرات بدون طيار
والمركبات البريه والبحريه غير ماهوله
تستلزم بعض التدخلات البشريه احيانا كما
هو معلوم
[موسيقى]
حذر رئيس المصاد نتانياهو من خطر الانقسام
الداخلي وتهديد الخارجي على امن اسرائيل
فيما حذر رئيس الاركان نتانياهو من ازمه
في الجيش اذا مرر قانون الاصلاح القضائي
بدوري استدعى رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيليين
نتنياهو وزير الدفاع يؤاف جالنت عقبه
تقارير اعلاميه اسرائيليه افادت بان وزير
الدفاع سيطالب بوقف الاصلاح القضائي
للحكومه فيما اتهم وزير الامن القومي
اتمار بن غفير وزير الدفاع بالتخلي عن
معسكر اليمين بهذا التصرف
قبل ذلك خرجت احتجاجات كبيره في 180 موقعا
باسرائيل ضد التعديلات القضائيه اليوم تحت
عنوان يوم الشلل الوطني واندلعت اشتباكات
عنيفه بين عناصر الشرطه والمتظاهرين في
منطقه العنانه بتل ابيب هذا وذكرت مراسله
العربيه بان من لا يقل عن 25 متظاهرا تم
اعتقالهم كما تظاهر عشرات الالاف في شارع
كابلان احد الشوارع الرئيسيه في تل ابيب
هذا وقد صادق الكنيسه الاسرائيليه على
قانون يضع قيودا على الحالات التي يمكن
فيها اقاله اي رئيس وزراء ويقول ائتلاف
الحاكم ان التعديلات تهدف الى ضبط التجاوز
الذي تمارسه المحكمه العليا في الصلاحيات
واعاده التوازن بين دوائر الحكم فيما يقول
معارضون ان القانون يهدف لحمايه بنيامين
نتنياهو من اي تبعات لمحاكماته بتهم فساد
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من القدسيات حلبي
مراسل العربيه للحديث اكثر عن الانقسامات
الداخليه وتحذير رئيس الاركان زياد هذه
التصريحات يعني هي ليست مفصليه ليست يعني
تفصيليه ابدا وانما مفصليه ماذا فيها وما
هي تداعياته
هذا صحيح جدا بدون ادنى شك بان ما يحدث
الان في اسرائيل باتت دراماتيكيا جدا خاصه
هذه الليله كما اسلفت في المقدمه وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي اوشك ان يخرج علنا ضد
نتنياهو والائتلاف ان يدعو الى وقف خطه
اضعاف القضاء انطلاقا من الفهم بان ذلك
عمليا سيفكك الجيش الاسرائيلي هذا ما قاله
مساء اليوم
بطبيعه الحال كان هناك لقاء وجيز جدا
حوالي عشر دقائق فقط بين نتنياهو وجلنت
على ما يبدو بان نتنياهو ضغط عليه
وبالتالي قد لا يخرج علنا وقد يتريث عده
ايام لكن نتنياهو سيخرج بعد بضع وقت يعني
بعد قليل وسيتحدث الى
الاسرائيليين اليوم رئيس الشباك
الاسرائيلي رئيس جهاز الامن العام اجتمع
مع نتنياهو عمليا وح بشكل واضح من ان
الانقسام الداخلي في اسرائيل التزاوج بين
هذا الانقسام وبين التهديدات الخارجيه تضع
اسرائيل امام خطر داهم رئيس هيئه الاركان
الاسرائيلي ايضا حذر من ان ما يحدث قد
يؤدي الى تصدع وتفكك الجيش
الاسرائيلي
هذه الليله سيتضح ما اذا كان نتنياهو
والائتلاف اليميني الذي بدا يتصدى على
فكره مع موقف ولكن يريد على زياد اسمح لي
عذرا على المقاطعه ولكن وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي بهذا العاجل الان يقول اطلعت
نتنياهو على تاثير التعديلات القضائيه على
الامن القومي وبالتالي يعني هذا يكمل ما
كنت تتحدث عنه التركيز على موضوع الامن
القومي بظل التحديات الخارجيه لاسرائيل
ماذا يعني
هذا صحيح جدا وكان نتنياهو لا يعرف عن
تهديد الامن القومي نتنياهو رئيس وزراء في
اسرائيل هو اكثر الناس درايه بالتهديدات
ولكن بدون ان تشك هناك ضغط الان من هيئه
الاركان على قلند بان يتخذ موقف قبل فوات
الاوان ولماذا قد يفوت الاوان عمليا ليال
لان هناك الان محاوله تمويه من الائتلاف
وكانها وكان الائتلاف يريد تخفيف هذه
الخطه وارجاء معظم البنود ولكن البند
الاهم يريد ان ان يمرره قانونا في خلال
اسبوع او اسبوعين وهو تغيير او السيطره
على لجنه تعيين القضاه ان حدث ذلك ستصبح
تهديدات ضباط الاحتياط في سلاح الجو
الاسرائيلي والوحدات الخاصه ليس مجرد
تهديدات بعصيان عسكري ستتحول شيئا فشيئا
الى العسكري لهذا عمليا ابلغ نتنياهو بان
ذلك سيفكك الجيش واسرائيل تذهب الى مجهول
عمليا وقد يجر هذا الحاسم الى الشارع بدون
ان هناك تهديدات خارجيه في اسرائيل في اي
لحظه وبالتالي غالنت يحاول ان يلوح في هذه
الورقه اليمين يتهمه الان بالخيانه
وبمحاوله اضعاف موقف اليمين ودعوا الى
اقالته شكرا لك زياده حلب بمراسل العربيه
حدثنا من القدس
مشاهدينا التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
الفرسان خريطه
الاعمال الدينيه والتاريخيه
بشاشه
في 2023
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الخميس الاسود كما اطلق
عليه المحتجون يشعل فرنسا قطع لطرقات
اضرابات واغلاقات ومظاهرات حاشده تنديدا
طبعا بقانون التقاعد الجديد الغضب على
القانون ومن اصدره يتزايد فاحتجاجات هذه
الاحتجاجات في فرنسا متواصله وزاد حجمها
وعدد المشاركين فيها في يوم اسماه الاعلام
الفرنسي الخميس الاسود السلطات الفرنسيه
مشاهدينا ولمواجهه الموجه التاسعه من
الاحتجاجات اتخذت تدابير امنيه اضافيه
وارسلت خمسه الاف من رجال الشرطه والدرك
لاداء طبعا مهامهم في العاصمه الفرنسيه
باريس هذا وكان قد اغلق المتظاهرون الطرق
المؤديه لمطار شاردي غول شمال فرنسا وعلى
اسره اوسط السلطات الفرنسيه الركاب
المسافرين باعاده جدوله سفرهم سفرهم طبعا
مع العلم بان عدد الرحلات قد تم تخفيضه في
معظم
الفرنسيه بنحو الثلث
مشاهدينا اعود الى هذه الصور المباشره من
العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس حيث كانت
الاحتجاجات دائره بين كل من المتظاهرين
والقوى الامنيه على ما يبدو بانها مستمره
مزيد من التفاصيل سينضم الينا من باريس
فادي الدهوك مراسل العربيه فادي كيف هي
الصوره من هناك
اهلا ليال التظاهرات ما زالت مستمره هي
كان من المتوقع ان تنتهي قرابه الساعه
السابعه قبل 45 دقيقه من الان لكن
المتظاهرين ما زالوا في الشوارع وايضا
تحدث مناوشات بينهم وبين عناصر الشرطه
التي تستخدم الغاز المسيل للدموع هذه
التظاهرات كانت ستنتهي في ساحه
لو سمحت سانتقل الى اسرائيل
ونتنياهو تصريح ونعود بلغ
الشيوطات
فقط
وانما ان تدعم حقوق كل المواطن ومواطن
لم ناتي لندمر ولندوس على الاخرين
لنحافظ
ولهذا نحن سنتقدم وسنصحح بشكل مسؤول
لاعاده التوازن
المطلوب بين السلطات وهذا جزء واحد من
الكثير من الغناقش ان المسار الافضل
لتحقيق الاصلاح واللي منع الصدع في الشارع
وبالتواصل الى التوافق عريض للاسف
حتى هذه الساعه
ممثلوه المعارضه رفضوا الدخول في الحوار
منذ ثلاثه اشهر
اامل ان يتغير ذلك الايام المقبله
انا اصغي
[موسيقى]
القانون
الذي سيطرح على المقبل ولا يسيطر نحن لا
نسيطر على لجنه الفضاء وانما نحدث توازن
وتنوع في المحكمه وفي الفيديوهات فهذا يوم
دغم من مد وهذا كان تم اقصاءه
لا نريد ان يكون
محكمه تحت السيطره وانما ان تكون
محكمه متوازنه ستكون محكمه الشعب
ستحظى
وهذا ليس النهايه الديمقراطيه وانما
يقول لك الديمقراطيه وفي كل الديمقراطيات
بما في ذلك الولايات المتحده
الممثل الجمهور هم من ينتخ
ب وهذا ليس نهايه الديمقراطيه
الرجل القضاء بشره المعروف من جامعه
هارفارما الذي
الاصلاح اذا كانت الاصلاح سيمر بدون هذه
التغييرات
المتحده كنت ستوريه وانما ستكون مثل كندا
ونيوزيلندا والولايات المتحده
هذا لدعميه الان
اريد
جانب الاخر وهناك مخاوف من فقرات تغلب
جارفه وغير متوازنه حتى يكون الاغلبيه
هذا ليس صحيح
لن يحدث ذلك العكس صحيح نحن وانا اريد ان
احافظ من خلال قانون على
حقوق الاساس لليهود وغيرها اذا مشاهدينا
استمعنا الى جزء من تصريح رئيس الحكومه
الاسرائيلي عن موضوع الاصلاحات القضائيه
وعن موضوع الانقسام الداخلي والامن القومي
الاسرائيلي اعود الى فرنسا وتحديدا الى
باريس ومراسل عربيه فادي الدهوك فادي اعود
لنقل الصوره من هناك معك تفضل
نعم ليال المتظاهرون ما زالوا متجمعين في
ساحه الاوبرا ويرفضون المغادره قوات
الشرطه تطوق هذه الساحه الان وايضا
المتظاهرين يقومون باشعال الحرائق كما
ترون على الشاشه هنا عدد من عناصر الاطفاء
يحاولون اطفاء هذا الحريق الذي اشعله
المتظاهرون لكن على العموم هناك عدد كبير
جدا شارك اليوم في التظاهرات في باريس
بحسب النقبات او نقابه سوجيتي هناك اكثر
من 800 الف شخص تظاهروا في العاصمه وحدها
اما في عموم فرنسا فان عدد المتظاهرين بلغ
ثلاثه ملايين ونصف المليون شخص بحسب ايضا
النقابات لكن الشرطه تقول ان اعدادهم هي
مليون وتسعه وثمانين الفن هذه التظاهرات
هي استمرار للحركه الاحتجاجيه ضد قانون
رفع سن التقاعد وما زاد ايضا من زخم هذه
التظاهرات هي التصريحات الرئيس ماكرون قبل
هذه التطورات او يوم امس تحديدا عندما
اعلن انه سيسير قدما في هذا الاصلاح
لتمويل المعاشات التقاعديه المتظاهرون
الان يقولون انهم سيواصلون تحركاتهم
للايام القادمه ايضا سيكون هناك اجتماع
للنقبات بعد ساعات من الان ليحددوا موعد
التحركات المقبله وطبيعتها في في هذه
التظاهره وقع بعض الاصابات رصدنا عدد من
الاصابات في صفوف المتظاهرين وايضا في
صفوف الشرطه كان هناك حاله من الفوضى
المتظاهرون كانوا يرشقون قوات الشرطه
بالحجاره وبالمقذوفات
بكل ما كانوا يجدونه في الشارع الشرطه
كانت ترد ايضا بالغاز المسيل للدموع وقامت
باعتقال عدد كبير من
المتحدثا نتابع تطور الاوضاع في الشارع
الفرنسي خلال تغطيتنا اللاحقه شكرا لك
حدثنا من باريس فادي الدهوك مراسل العربيه
ختام التاسعه مشاهدينا مع العناوين
في جلسه استجواب لمديره التنفيذي الكونغرس
تيك توك بالتحريض والتجسس لصالح الصين
[تصفيق]
يدعو للاستعداد لمواجهه الصين وينقل
طائرات حديثه من الشرق الاوسط الى جنوب
شرقي اسيا
مدى عاما هاتا يتهم ترامب بنشر توقعات
خاطئه حول اعتقاله لدفع الجمهوريين
بالتدخل بالتحقيق
الخميس الاسود يشعل فرنسا قطع للطرقات
واشتباكات بين الامن ومتظاهرين ضد قانون
التقاعد
الى هنا اتي الى ختام التاسعه اخبر
العربيه مستمره طبعا كما كل ليله الان الى
360 والزميل ميسون نواهد ميسون ماذا لديك
الليله مساء الخير مساء الخير ليال طبعا
ازمه تيك توك تتصدر الاخبار وهذا الحظر
الذي يتعرض له هذا التطبيق الموضوع الثاني
ايضا ما زالت قضيه ترامب وايضا تتصدر
الاخبار وخاصه موضوع المدعي العامه
والتصعيد مع الجمهوريين كما ايضا ذكر بان
هناك ادانا وندد بالتدخل المشرعين وايضا
هناك موضوع تاكيد الكونجرس بالنصين معا